we believe that what we are building is
is uh you know bringing more
transparency transparency in the food uh
for the world and
we really expect to cover five percent
of the world food and make it more safer
transparent
and sustainable welcome to 20 minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
really excited for this episode because
this company May really be changing how
we think through food supply chains
quality assurance of our products from
the farmer to the retail stores and the
founders has a lot of conviction about
where he's headed so so stay tuned for
this episode meet taranjit Singh bamra
the CEO and founder of agnex
Technologies a globally award-winning
Venture capital-backed company it's
evolved it's solving for trust and
transparency in global value chains
using an AI based solution for enabling
quality-based assessments taranjit is a
graduate of IIT current core and IIM
Calcutta he's an accomplished
professional and business leader having
worked for more than 20 years in
strategy Consulting Investment Banking
and high impact entrepreneurial roles in
Indian and international markets his
Ambitions are endless it resonates
through this episode really excited to
to listen to this again myself and
please enjoy
foreign
I'm really excited to be talking to you
about agnext and your own story looking
at Global supply chain for food quality
assurance obviously you know the world
is progressing and technology is
Shifting and you know so many different
Industries and I'm really excited to
pick your brain on what you're doing
with agnext
um in the world today so again thank you
for being here to run and and let's
start tell me a little bit about
yourself and your own Journey leading up
to the formation of agnext how do you
how did you get into sort of agriculture
in the food supply chain
rather but it's a long story short uh
it's been a it's the Genesis is more
than 25 years old when I was in
engineering uh doing my you know
engineering I always thought that what
is it that I could do something to apply
technology for the larger good
and uh you know it was very it was the
most easiest way to move on to some PhD
and then just join some you know
University and be a professor or or be a
honcho in the Wall Street or something
like that but for me it was like you
know the real engineering if applied on
the ground
how I can I can build something for the
larger uh you know for the larger impact
and uh I don't know this thought was is
quite seen to be uh you know coming
towards later part of life it came to me
a bit earlier so uh I think for me it
was uh going on the ground I worked in
rural uh rural Supply chains uh to
understand you know what are the
problems that have been faced in
agriculture and uh after that uh you
know that gave me a very very good
insight about you know where the supply
chains lack where incentives for the
farmers are not being built and uh how
does you know very long Supply chains in
the food get disrupted owing to lack of
Technology
well tell me a little bit about that
because I think that's fascinating so
share with me some of your perspective
on sort of the inefficiencies of the
supply chain anything you know with with
fairness transparency and quality
assurance so what what are the big
problems that we're facing in the world
today
see anything that you buy in this uh in
this world right uh you buy it on two
access the axis of quantity and the axis
of quality right so the intersection of
quantity and quality is the price so you
pay a particular price for a particular
quality and a particular quantity
now the trillions of dollars that you
buy food in Food Vegetarian from the
farmers or from the Traders or from the
warehouses
every time you buy the entire Quality
Inspection is subjective
trillions of dollars
so that's where the time of the whole
Market lies that you know if you can if
you can digitize the Quality Inspection
that really transforms and gives more
transparency it gives more profitability
to the buyer because uh at the at the
subjectivity point lies all the
malpractices utilize all the
inefficiencies in the supply chain
so I worked in Supply chains globally
for multiple Brands and built a lot of
solutions around supply chain visibility
and then went on to Consulting and data
Sciences uh I worked in around 15
countries so that gave me an idea that
you know that if I focus to you know
analyze quality or rather digitized
quality without any human intervention
without any inhuman subjectivity
it will be applied in every transaction
in the food value chain that was the
thought that then our technology becomes
ephemeral in the sense that it will be
there uh you know everywhere where
transaction is happening
so that was the whole idea for us to you
know get into such a uh I would say uh
building a technology 2016 I came back
to India I was working in around 15
countries then Lock Stock Barrel I I had
a two-year-old kid and my wife and we
said let's go back and do something
great so it wasn't an easy Journey
because uh when I came back to India uh
you know somebody talking about
technology and data it was like what the
hell is this guy talking about so it
took me around five years to build
technology I would say uh data in
agriculture we took around around 3
million food samples uh in in spices in
in tea in Greens uh oil seeds and then
set up a lab and then I worked
vehemently on building devices which can
do computer vision and spectral Sciences
so we are today one of the leaders in
computer uh computer science uh computer
vision analysis and and spectral
Sciences and that makes us uh you know
now prevalent uh application that needs
to be provided wherever buying and
selling is happening so we are at the
farm gate we are at the warehouse we are
at the factories uh now into exports now
uh you know various governments
blockchains wanting us to tie up with
them so that you know International
Supply chains can be more assured uh
more transparent and the description
that kovit has bought uh with you know
so much of supply chain inefficiencies
being you know exposed that can be sold
using a technology and bias can be more
assured about you know what you're
buying but the largest impact that we do
is
the other end of creating a report card
for a farmer right right because yeah
it's like you know you're the best in
the class or you're the worst in the
class you will get the same job so yeah
that that is what used to happen with
the farmers because you know
there was no incentive for the farmer to
create quality because right whatsoever
Lord you go the buyer would say oh you
know what I'll give you this prize
because your quality is not good now who
defines that quality right so digitizing
that has given me that you know at least
that comfort that you know what we are
doing is a real world once in a
generation effort because building this
three million food samples and then
building this technology it's a Once in
a generation effort by a company and I
think going forward we we are more than
happy that you know so many companies
want us so many governments want us so I
think it's it's we just need to be more
stronger in our Pace to build this and I
think there are so many immense
opportunities for us to capture in any
food value chain so you call it a meat
food value chain grains food value chain
oil seeds
so I think that's where we are happy and
we believe that what we are building is
is uh you know bringing more
transparency transparency in the food uh
for the world and
we really expect to cover five percent
of the world food and make it more safer
transparent
and sustainable incredible incredible
how do you get sort of people to agree
on a standard for quality of
of food so you mentioned part of the
promises subjectivity how do you you
know you leverage obviously technology
to give some sort of score but how do
you get
all the stakeholders from the farmers to
the buyers and Distributors
manufacturers retailers to agree on what
is a standard rubric for food
so well uh it's a the answer is very
interesting here you know what exists
and what does not and I can divide the
answer into two so what exists is
that wherever trade happens so the the
current systems already Define uh kind
of we call it as you know Fair average
quality or at least the quality
parameters on which we analyze the
entire activity
uh that was done subjectively uh by
people now so we have used computer
vision to totally use it and kind of you
know replace it and show that these are
against the already set parameters that
are governed by that particular trade or
that particular supply chain in that
particular uh node of supply chain which
is basically a warehouse or a phone cave
now the second thing that never existed
was if I were to do the you know the
proximate analysis or if you call it how
much is the protein there how much is
the fat percentage there or how much is
a active compartment of spice all of
that used to happen in the in the labs
and uh you know that's where most money
is made actually by kind of you know uh
not being sure about what's that what's
the quality and they said oh this is bad
quality so if you could do it on the
spot uh rapidly that is where the real
technology uh application of us comes in
so that's what we've made using spectral
Sciences
and uh what was done in labs in 10 days
we can do that in one minute on the
ground
and so who who is actually actively
using the spectral analysis and the
computer vision is it the farmers that
are actively examining their products
how does this actually work in the field
yeah so uh it's kind of a robin and
strategy for us right now so we are
giving it B2B so uh we are primarily
focusing on the businesses who want to
ensure that what they're buying is of
the right quality so we never charge the
farmer we charge the businesses for
using our application on a SAS model
wherever they are buying they they keep
our technology and every lot that they
buy they they analyze through our
technology yeah so they basically go to
the you know take samples from what they
get or they go to the farm and then they
are able to sort of understand what is
the quality of produce that this farmer
and then do the farmers how do they
react all of a sudden to having them be
able to identify very quickly the
quality do they like it do they resist
yeah yeah so the good part is that the
farmers have started liking it because
they if when companies start using it
for evaluating and pride giving them
pricing and it's done by a machine
so they for them that kind of gives them
a you know that next next season I would
come with a better quality
so you know the same thing happened in
India in 40 years back with white
Revolution where you know India was very
low in milk production and uh you know
there was there was a call to improve
the overall milk production in India
it's called the white Revolution and one
of the ways it was improved was you know
that the buyers got into the daily
companies they got into something called
the lactometer which gave them you know
what's the fat and the solid non-fat
percentage in milk
so on the spot so any added person you
get a higher price at six percent you
get a lower price so farmers were happy
to see that they went back and they kind
of you know brought worked hard to bring
a better goal review so I think this is
what we are doing for literally every
commodity in the world so initially the
reaction is uh you know
for a few few places where they have
been bringing low quality the idea was
so we need to improve so I think that's
the good part for us that the overall
index of Agriculture will improve with
the technology
and that's what is sustainability I love
it so you're actually saying that a
consequence of of providing this series
of incentives is that you're effectively
increasing the overall index of the
quality of the food because you're
providing Market incentives that
previously weren't in place for the
farmers to escape absolutely so lots
lots more economics and psychology
coming into place along with technology
here and beautiful beautiful now you
mentioned
um sort of five percent
um Global Supply Chain go live can you
elaborate on that a little bit sort of
what is sort of the vision for AG next
in the world and sort of a strategy for
getting there oh that's a moonshot so we
said that you know that every every lot
every food supply chain that that is
inspected by us is fairer is is sounds
like it is is incentivized Laden so
so we just said that you know how much
of the food we'll be able to cover sure
before our IPO
so I said uh I mean I I was sitting in
the day I said
five percent won't be bad so I think
let's go for dinner covering and that's
a huge that itself is to you know of a
trillion dollars maybe
incredible but but so if you're looking
at the world as a whole I mean obviously
this is something that's relevant for
the entire world right not just for for
specific areas I mean what are sort of
some high-level strategies that that go
into place here as you're thinking about
scaling this product once you've reach
product Market fit and you see that this
is working you know across a specific
supply chain how do you how do you scale
this thing massively yeah so uh the good
part is that we have a very uh
steadfastly focused
on only few Commodities we are to
understand that once we make it uh in
one geography we can take it to
geography and right it's it's just
purely by you know how we can uh just
kind of calibrate at the geography and
then kind of you know utilize this
technology because this is a universal
need of this technology
so if I have done wheat in India
I can take wheat uh in Australia or I
can take uh you know rice in India I can
take rice in Vietnam
so that was the idea that we focused on
few Commodities and then take it to
various geographies where they are
number two or number three so one of
them is
focused Commodities uh expanding into
you know focused geographies so this is
one strategy that we are envisaging to
grow together
and is there a common standard for
quality of wheat across different
geographies is there sort of a common
baseline or standard that you can adhere
to
yes so the computer vision analysis for
wheat globally is along the same
parameters interesting well there are 10
to 11 parameters that are analyzed using
physical quality of wheat
they are almost the same uh you know
with some changes tweaks here and there
which we can kind of you know calibrate
for the chemical analysis for example
the gluten and the protein is is it Con
it's common across the world for wheat
to be analyzed on that so I think that
that's how we have kind of you know
built our our algorithms that you know
if we can analyze it wheat in one
geography can we take it to the next and
I think that the second is tying up uh
with local Partners uh who can who can
take this technology and go to all food
inspections that are happening uh you
know and that's a that's a very good uh
strategy for scaling uh it's a very good
you know organic growth as well for us
because
uh literally every country has food
inspections uh if you digitize that
there's a massive massive opportunity to
build a a very very solid global
technology uh with an IPO story
interesting so Toronto take me back a
little bit to your own personal Journey
you've mentioned that you've sort of
honed in on this uh on this idea of
global impact at scale earlier than
traditional it happens and it definitely
sounds like it what is sort of this
vision for you what does this company
mean for your own personal story in life
I think we all come to live only a few
years and uh
whatever we study whatever we do uh I
think
uh if you do what you are passionate
about you don't feel tired and uh you
know uh everything that you have
manifested or or thought about kind of
uh keeps getting real so uh that's where
the real journey uh for any individual
uh you know for me is exciting because
uh I I don't follow templates of you
know particular X and then Y and then z
uh I I choose 25 years back then you
know I would want to create technology
for for the world and it took me 25
years that's not a small amount of time
of almost one third of my life so much
but that helped me to you know
keep working at it and kind of you know
building on it so for me agnics is
everything that we can do for you know
the Next Generation uh and that next
generation is also my kids so I want to
ensure that safe food uh you know more
more safer food more sustainable world
uh exist uh as I leave my kids to Earth
so I think that's what keeps me very
happy uh that what I'm doing is
something for the greater good uh I mean
I have just enjoyed this journey so for
me it's it's just about doing it and I
think I prepared myself over a long
period of time to to keep working and
delivering this so I think that's what
uh that's what is very very exciting and
it sounds like you're already you're
you're the reality that you're living in
is sort of already the possibility of of
AG next being a world leader in in sort
of spectral analysis computer vision
when it comes to the to the global
supply chain I mean your shirt literally
says agnex to wear Unstoppable what is
this sort of how does this sort of this
relentlessness unstoppableness why is
this such a big factor in the way that
you perceive your your journey here
I think uh VL and stoppable because we
have now found uh you know the the
Mantra the algorithm to to analyze food
and solve the 50 uh of a transaction and
and giving incentives to Farmer and
giving profitability to the buyer so I
think uh that's what uh and I think that
was that was The Da Vinci Code of of
commodity buying that you know if we if
we can analyze quality that makes
commodity buying more sexier if I would
say the word is cook I think uh that's
why uh we believe that
uh it is up to us
to now utilize this Tech uh
deployed multiple geographies multiple
commodity value chains and more
important in the uh tie up I always say
we don't have any competitor because
what we are trying to do here is you
know we have created a niche and uh now
literally whether it's a commodity
exchange or whether whether it is
corporates or whether it is you know
exporters all of them aren't want our
technology so for us it's about
dissipating and finding a a channel to
you know dissipate a technology at every
transaction so that's why you know we
kind of agree this is that song we are
unstoppable which my son kind of
introduced me to so he said awesome why
don't you hear this song so I said well
I was listening when I was going on a
drive with him and I I did a town hall
and I showed this song and returned
everyone was yes
I think yeah so I play a guitar uh so I
I think I'll play this to to the I will
play with my you know team to this song
and that really justifies what we are
doing we
so so inspiring thank you so much for
this time and for the great work that
you're doing I'm so excited to continue
following agnext as a fan from the side
um thank you for for all the great work
and the inspiration and best of luck
with the AG next and thank you very very
much
thank you Michael such a pleasure to be
here it was awesome
[Music]